samedi matin les faits du bien ici ont
accueilli le compte
deux têtes le pigeon
14 200 enfants âgés entre
présent élèves des cm1 et cm2 et 72
écoles n'est pas possible ça annécien
compte appris à monter des lignes à
appâter et à pêcher sous la vigilance
des par un pêcheur qui désenclave
quelles sont ces mini pc puis déversée
dans le canal du
lebon ressources publiques en france
ouvert à 9 heures
beaucoup de khanh hoà aux organes des
espérances des organisateurs qui avaient
plus que gâtés les gens
on prend les équipements portée
dans l'ordre
il autorise le but est principalement de
sensibiliser les enfants aux problèmes
de l'eau et de l'environnement
nous avons donc mis en place dans les
écoles un dossier pédagogique qui dans
le cadre du tiers-temps a été commentée
par les instituteurs les enfants
partiront tous avec une canne à pêche
n'est ce pas du matériel de pêche
jusqu'à la gagne elle quitte tous les
enfants auront une récompense et a pris
combien de poissons qui fait les voir
son gros moyens moyens clusaz prix ou
oui c'était du sort les du sac là à vous
recevoir un peu obbadi dont elle est
belle hein
un pigeon pour qu'ils trouvent comme ça
là quatre autres comme ça c'est la
première fois que tu paies cher
non c'est son pays dans le monde qui va
à la pêche avec ton papa
et bien souvent la pêche moi c'est un
premier pas dit non pour la première
fois c'est un coup de maître
qu'est ce qu'il va faire tous poissons
pour ma famille il va le ramener chez
toi et ce soir tu vas de manger la ville
d'annecy et l'association des pêcheurs a
les siennes punta cana
parmi tous ces jeunes amateurs en plus
d'autres cours la majorité d'entre eux
qui n'avaient jamais trempé dans l'eau a
bien l'intention maintenant de
persévérer et de taquiner
dont l'épaisseur est black grand père il
ya mêlé d'arpèges piqûre de ces jeunes
amateurs
elle sera peut-être marque aussi
miraculeux que celle de ce dernier saad